okay we've come to the end of
sledgehammer week
today's Friday yeah no better smashing I
get out about you oh very funny
especially good show right final item of
the week is a tube from an old crappy
CRT screen television on television now
we've already done a hammer through the
front of the screen so what should we do
with this one I can sledgehammer through
the top of the screen
yeah so happens we will know how fast
glass crash I predict will be gone in
one frame the whole screen shattered
yeah yeah one frame it will take my
prediction like one half we have a
one-shot wonder this one oh go ahead in
the face by actually you're hit in the
face hahaha
I'm glad I smoked my last nakid it did
yeah I enjoyed that good actually really
pop I got hit in the side of the head
with a bit of a bit of flying shrapnel
all right let's see how many frames this
last crack tip I reckon I was good in
the kitchen I reckon one the heart was
correct so alright there's their pack
weight 1/2 big one up one huh oh I was
two for three three frames of cranberry
frames I think I was close to more than
half so yeah you're right and it went
from this yeah well that's how fast it
goes what's that video game show where
you have to guess the price or something
Price is Right price is right and then
you say are they two thousand pounds and
someone goes two thousand and one pound
yeah cuz if you're over you get nothing
yeah but if you're under vibe like 100
you can actually win just like it
someone just like be that guy you were
like it's gonna crack in one frame I was
like one and a half frame I can't even
venture for a full frame well what would
be the repair cost on that look at all
that in there didn't know song like a
further take it's probably probably in a
lot of glue I imagine just a lot of sort
of TV glue is there such a thing as the
cheesy bite on the shelf yeah yeah
that's little I imagine that's some sort
of electron firing device Oh careful
duh hello it's like a sort of this
gramophone optical thanks for joining us
on our amazing sledgehammer adventure
this week check back next week for our
regular content again but hope you
enjoyed it see you next time
you